CDU und Steuererhöhung sind so zwei
Begriffe die Griechen noch nicht so
richtig zusammen sie offenbar schon
wessen Idee war das
das heißt Steuererhöhungen also die
Frage ist was heißt das also was machen
gar keine Steuerung
also die Frage ist
sollen wir fragen 20 Steuern 20 Jahren
eine große Steuerreform machen wenn wir
die machen ja
Soli meines Erachtens komplett
abschaffen eigentlich schon seit Jahren
weil wir das den Leuten versprochen
haben
zweitens muss der sogenannte
Mittelstandsbauch abgeschafft werden
mittelstandsbrauch bedeutet
plastisch zu sagen in den 60er 70er
Jahren müssten sie das 15 bis 20-fache
des durchschnittlichen Lohnes verdienen
und dann mussten sie den
Spitzensteuersatz zahlen als die
sogenannte grenzsteuer heute das
Anderthalbfache also jemand der 63000 €
verdient ab 63.000 % und damit treffen
sie komplett die Mittelschicht weil wir
jahrelang nichts gemacht haben ja und
wenn Sie das Abbauen entlasten sie auch
überproportional Menschen die 800.000
Euro im Jahr verdienen und da ist die
Frage ob wir in diesen Zeiten wo wir
sechs bis acht Prozent Inflation haben
und nicht bei den Formen auf diejenigen
konzentrieren die es wirklich brauchen
und deswegen will ich diejenigen die
viel verdienen nicht zusätzlich
entlasten aber auch nicht belasten und
deswegen ist es am Ende egal wenn Sie
den Steuertarif sagen Sie mal ich nehme
jetzt mal diese 63.000 und die würden in
Zukunft ab 100.000 gelten das heißt
jemand der so ein versteuerndes
Einkommen von 100.000 im Jahr hat muss
den Spitzensteuersatz zahlen wenn wir ab
diesem Zeitpunkt dann den Steuertarif
hochziehen werden selbst Einkommen die
Hunderttausende im Jahr verdienen nicht
zusätzlich
[Musik]
belastet weil sie entlastet werden
lustig oder ich habe gerade nach
Steuererhöhungen gefragt und sie
antworten gefühlt 2 Minuten 30 und das
Wort Steuererhöhung kam kann kein
einziges Mal stattdessen über
Entlastungen gesprochen genau
es gibt keine Steine Begriff
Steuererhöhung so suggeriert ja ja dass
ich entlasten will ja bzw
ich will aber entlassen genau und das
ist nämlich mein Problem und deswegen
wollen
sie machen wo wollen
gar nicht also unterm Strich ja
Steuererhöhung heißt ja eigentlich dass
ich belasten also CDU
gegensteuererhöhungen ich möchte eine
große Steuerzahler schließt
Steuererhöhungen aus erlanz ich möchte
aus ich möchte eine große Steuerreform
und am Ende ist es egal wo der Tarif
liegt bei hohen Einkommen weil
grundsätzlich fast alle entlastet werden
weil die Entlastungswirkung vorne
Solingen Mittelstand Bauch weg so groß
ist das selbst jemand der eine Million
verdient im Jahr noch entlastet wird und
deswegen möchte ich den Steuertarif
erhöhen dass der nicht so stark
entlastet wird sondern nur wenig
aufgrund sein
in Tarif will ich eine Steuererhöhung ja
am Ende Stelle am Ende okay das ist ein
Grundsatzprogramm wir reden über eine
grundsätzliche Steuerreform und ich kann
in der heutigen Zeit keine Steuerreform
machen wo ich jemand der im Jahr ein zu
versteuerndes Einkommen von einer
Million hat noch um 50 60.000 entlassen
sie es nicht einfach verstehe ich jetzt
nicht es versteht keiner was sie gerade
hier erklärt sagen Sie doch einfach weil
das kommt ganz viele Leute entlasten und
einige wenige wollen sie deutlich höher
belasten das ist doch das Ding oder
nicht genau das sind einige weniger ja
das ist so das stimmt okay also noch mal
bei wem gibt es Steuerungen ab wie viel
Euro das ist ein Grundsatzprogramm weil
bei demjenigen der das muss man je
nachdem wie stark ich unentlaste wenn
ich unten stark entlaste wird also der
Steuerzahler Bund hat es mal gerechnet
okay und der kam auf Einkommen in Höhe
von einer Million oder 1,2 Millionen ab
diesem Zeitpunkt
also ich erzähle jetzt mal gerne was die
CDU geschlossen hat ja um erstmal das
klar zu haben es geht um eine
Steuerentlastung von 50 Milliarden Euro
diese Steuerentlastung kommt dadurch
zustande dass der Soli abgeschafft
werden soll
den Zahlen im Augenblick nur noch die
hohen Einkommensbezieher also die
obersten fünf Prozent der Bevölkerung da
geht schon mal um 10 Milliarden dann
kommt die Entlastung dadurch zustande
dass man den Steuertarif streckt davon
profitieren alle davon streckt heißt
jetzt beginnt der Spitzensteuersatz bei
ungefähr
62000 und dann soll der
Spitzensteuersatz künftig bei 100.000
gezahlt werden was für eine gute
Nachricht ist genau und davon dieser
Entlastung profitieren aber nicht nur
die Leute die sagen wir mal 80.000
verdienen sondern von dieser Entlastung
profitieren alle in egal wie viel Sie
verdienen weil ja alle immer nach
Progression zahlen und dann soll es noch
eine Unternehmenssteuerreform geben um
das mal kurz zusammenzufassen die von
dieser Steuerreform profitieren im
Wesentlichen die sehr gut Verdiener und
ein bisschen aber nur ein bisschen die
obere Mittelschicht so und aber vor
allen Dingen profitieren alle Leute die
Mittelstandsbauch abschaffen treffe ich
doch genau die unteren nein weil die
Progression trifft alle ja das war ja
auch eben mein Argument
deswegen wollen wir hinten den Tarif
erhöhen sie aber nicht sondern hinten
wissen doch ich habe ja ihr Programm
gelesen und da steht
sie haben doch darüber bei der Ludwig
Erhard Tagung schon erzählt
und da steht das alles drin so also und
sie haben nicht gegen den weltartikel
widersprochen und da konnte man dann
erkennen dass der Spitzensteuersatz von
42 auf 45% steigen sollen doch im
Programm nicht zwischen 42 auf 45 geht
einfach um die Frage wir müssen die
Arbeiten der Bevölkerung in Deutschland
entlasten die ersticken unter hohen
Sozialabgaben und Steuern so und wir
wollen einfach nicht alle in dem Maße
entlasten weil sie das in dieser Zeit
nicht aushalten und deswegen sollen
diejenigen die sehr gut verdienen nicht
so entlastet werden und einige wenige ja
werden zusätzlich belaste so habe ich
jetzt auch nicht schlimm so also
wirklich
gespannt
was von Wirtschaft wir müssen doch Leute
die eine Million verdienen
45% zahlen weil die die Reichensteuer
zahlen müssen
aber gar nicht mehr vor
Sie sind nicht richtig im Bilder ich
wäre sogar bereit auf 48 oder 49% zu
gehen
die werden noch entlastet
weil am Anfang die Entlastung über den
Soli und den Mittelstandsbauch so schwer
wie ich das ist ja das Argument was ich
die ganze Zeit sagen will dass ich
selbst Einkommen im höheren Bereich
entlastet und das genau aber man kann
zusammen logisch man kann aber
zusammenfassen die Entlastung die sehr
substanziell ist wird vor allen Dingen
die Gutverdiener der günstigen
jemand der heute Mindestlohn der heute
Mindestlohn hat
natürlich seit der steuern also die die
dreistelligen Bereich ja aber die Zahlen
so wenig Steuern dass so wenig Zeit
heute dreimal so viel wie vor der
mindestlohnerhöhung das heißt auch die
unteren Einkommen treffen sie und jedes
Mal Frau Herrmann wenn sie unten
entlasten entlassen sie ja auch oben mit
ja eben so und deswegen ziehen wir den
Tarif höher weil diejenigen die oben
sind nicht zu stark entlastet werden
recht einige werden dann auch zusätz
Spaß zwischen den beiden Herr südekum
für mich ich verstehe davon nicht
wirklich was aber für mich klingt das
eigentlich nach keinem wirklich
schlechten Plan also es klingt so als
hätte die CDU plötzlich so eine soziale
Ader entdeckt hatte sie immer schon aber
jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr
falsch ich kommentiere ein bisschen ins
Blaue hinein weil wir noch nicht
wirklich wissen was der Vorschlag ist es
gibt so eine Gerüchte Lage und die
Gerüchte die man heute so liest oder
gestern das sind ein bisschen anderer
als die Gerüchte die man vor drei Wochen
gelesen habe
von Erbschaftssteuer heute heißt es soll
jetzt eben doch keine Fundament
kommen die Konfusion hier ist äh diese
Komplexität mit den grenzsteuer setzen
und der Progression ich glaube einfacher
zu verstehen ist wenn man über
Durchschnittssteuersatz redet
und jemand der Spitzensteuersatz bei der
Grenzbelastung bezahlt der zahlt ja
nicht 42% Steuer beim Durchschnitt
sondern jemand mit 60.000 da sind es
noch nicht mal 30 Prozent die im
Durchschnitt gezahlt werden weil der
Spitzensteuersatz erst für jeden Euro
jenseits von 60.000 grob gesagt fällig
werden
höre dass alle entlastet werden soll nur
unterschiedlich stark die Rechnung wird
nicht aufgeben weil dann werden die
Steuereinnahmen aus der Einkommensteuer
entsprechend wegbrechen und dann müssen
wir ja irgendwie gucken wo soll dann
dieses Geld herkommen wichtiger eine
echte aufkommensneutrale Reform wäre
tatsächlich auch was die Durchschnitt
Steuersätze angeht oben zu belasten und
dann Mittel zu haben um unten und in der
Mitte Entlastung zu machen
was wirklich ich glaube das größte
Problem ist vor allem der Bereich unten
ja also im Grundfreibetrag Leute die im
Jahr so zwischen 10 und 20.000 nicht
viel da gibt es nämlich die größten
Universitäten das nämlich
gerade angesprochen hat das ist
natürlich noch nicht als den
Mittelstandsbauch bezahlt werden möchte
also das ist quasi unten die Problematik
dass jemand ein Euro brutto mehr
verdient und de facto am Ende weniger
Geld in der Tasche hat weil die Steuer
reinschlägt dieses handwerksbeiträge
reinschlagen und der Anspruch auf
bestimmte Sozialleistung zum Beispiel
Wohngeld entsprechend entfällt in kürzt
wird das muss trinken geändert werden
das war nicht und das kostet aber Geld
wenn man das entlassen kostet das Geld
dann muss man oben auch wirklich
tatsächlich stärker okay und das das
zweite uns einmal jetzt mal sozusagen
nach oben da weiter durchzuarbeiten
Mittel dann Mittelschicht ist gerade
gefallen das selber auch auf vielen
Reisen so gesehen wenn man durch Amerika
fährt kann man sich das angucken
also in dieser Globalisierung die für
viele Leute sehr viel Wohlstand gebracht
hat ja sie beschreiben das auch sehr
eindrucksvoll in dem Buch was
Globalisierung eigentlich
an viele Ecken für ein großer Erfolg war
aber die Mittelschicht in in vielen
Industrieländern ist dabei schwer unter
die Räder gekommen das heißt es ist doch
völlig in Ordnung zu sagen wie entlasten
genau diese Leute die heute einen
Großteil ihres Einkommens für Miete
Inflation was auch immer einfach
ausgeben müssen und am Ende bleibt
nichts davon übrig nein das ist doch ein
vernünftiges Programm also man sagen
würde Stärke Belastung oben und dafür
entlaste unten in der Mitte ist dass das
aus meiner Sicht ein vernünftiges
Programm und entspricht in etwa dem was
bei der SPD bei den Grünen
Parteiprogramm steht da nicht warum
haben Sie es in der Zeit der großen
Koalition nicht gemeinsam mit der SPD
gemacht weil das nicht gut war weil ich
das immer kritisiert habe weil dieses
Land sich eigentlich nur um diejenigen
kümmert die unten sind und ganz oben die
haben keine Probleme das Bürgergeld ist
super organisiert die Sozialleistungen
laufen super aber die Leute die hier
arbeiten gehen die die sich einsetzen
die Leisten die Fallen hinten drüber
also nach Deutschland kommen aus dem
Ausland wir sind nicht attraktiv genug
weil wir die höchsten Steuern haben nach
Belgien ein gutes ziehen sogar welche
weg wegen unserer steuern und der hohen
Sozialamt alles richtig
der jetzt sich sozusagen abzeichnet den
hätte man ja aus einem hätte man auch in
der vergangenen Prinzip ja so umsetzen
können
ehrlicher Wahlkampf zu werden weil man
muss jetzt mal sagen dass die Belastung
der Mittelschicht kommt nicht durch die
Steuern sondern durch die Sozialabgaben
nicht beides sondern durch die
Sozialarbeiter Abgaben können Sie auch
bei der OECD nachlesen so die an diesem
Sozialabgaben ändern sie aber gar nichts
sie ändern nur was an der Steuer und
zwar deswegen weil die Spitzenverdiener
damals nichts an Sozialabgaben zahlen
sondern vor allen Dingen an Steuern und
ihr ganzes Programm so wie wir es jetzt
kennen ist darauf ausgelegt dass die
Wohlhabenden vor allen Dingen die
Wohlhabenden entlastet werden denn wie
gesagt insgesamt wollen sie 50
Milliarden entlasten sie haben keine
Gegenfinanzierung die Gegenfinanzierung
soweit man das bisschen
hören konnte soll darin bestehen dass
man bei den Sozialausgaben des Staates
kürzt das heißt das ist ein Programm wo
am Ende die Reichen profitieren und der
Rest profitiert entweder gar nicht oder
muss sogar noch Einsparungen hinnehmen
CDU-Politiker der sagt wenn wir diese
Tarifreform machen dann ist es am Ende
egal ob wir beim Spitzensteuersatz für
wohlhabende bei 42 bei 45 wird sogar
sagen bei 49
langfristig gehen die die Franzosen 70
gegangen
in Konrad Adenauer Urlaubsort da getagt
haben immer der große Arbeiterführer
Helmut Kohl hatte genau
unter 50 nur ich sitze hier und sage das
und das kritisieren sie dann noch ich
bin mir sicher vorher Mann vor drei
Wochen hätten sie nie gedacht dass ein
CDU-Politiker hier sitzt und sowas sagt
und deswegen glauben Sie mir das ist
überhaupt gar keine soziale Kälte die
wir hier austragen sondern ich glaube
einfach dass diese Masse an Menschen das
sind Millionen die sind zu langweilig
für die Schlagzeile die wohnen auch
nicht in Berlin Mitte wo die
Journalisten sind sondern die sind im
ländlichen Raum überall verteilt und die
haben die Schnauze voll dass wir uns um
die seit Jahren nicht kümmern auch in
der großen Koalition nicht deshalb
müssen was machen und das ist das Ziel
eine Frage stellen
wird es jetzt wie hoch wird die
Entlastung insgesamt sein wie viele
Milliarden werden das sein
Grundsatzprogramm für die nächsten 10 15
Jahre ich bin in die Politik gegangen um
dieses Land nach vorne zu bringen wir
sind kurz davor es vor die Wand zu
fahren alle Ecken und Enden überall
läuft es nicht mehr wir haben Fachkräfte
Problem inflationsprobleme vieles mehr
und jetzt lassen Sie uns doch mal
kümmern um diese diesen Teil der
Gesellschaft
und ganz ehrlich da muss man hinterher
gucken ja wir müssen neue Prioritäten
setzen und den einen Punkt hat vorher
mein Recht na dann wenn diese
zeitenwände haben und neue Prioritäten
setzen dann müssen wir auch ehrliches
Programm machen mit unbequem Wahrheiten
und das ist auch meine meine
Widerspruch
machen sie in Friedrich Schmerz sind
sozusagen die die ehrlich Brothers der
Politik nein ich möchte 2025 einen
ehrlichen Wahlkampf ich möchte das
wirklich das Sagen sie so das heißt die
anderen waren nicht ehrlich bis jetzt in
den ist das erste Mal dass sie das
machen ehrlich in den letzten Jahren
schauen sich doch die FDP die Grünen die
SPD an warum muss man das Betonen ja sie
werden doch nicht gewählt für unbequeme
Wahrheiten da sagt man doch immer das
erste mal ehrlich 25 nein ich sehe als
ich sage nein insgesamt alle Parteien
wollen doch immer wieder gewählt werden
wollen doch meine Kleine andere das
heißt die Leute werden vorsätzlich
belogen nein die werden nicht
vorsätzlich belogen sondern man sagt
nein
Wahlkampf erlebt wo man im Ansatz
erklärt hat wie man die ganzen
versprechen die man im Wahlkampf ausruft
bezahlen machen sie gerade auch nicht
doch
drüber reden
wollen das ist tatsächlich ein bisschen
höher gerade an Ehrlichkeit ist wenn ich
noch mal einen Wahlkampf 21 zurückdenke
sowohl bei der CDU als auch bei der FDP
dann kann das Recht zusammen im Prinzip
daraus zu sagen wir wollen für alle
möglichen Dinge mehr ausgeben
Investitionen wir wollen alle steuerlich
entlasten und auf gar keinen Fall neue
Schulden machen und dass dieser Dreisatz
nicht aufgeht das ist wohl klar deswegen
insofern ist es jetzt ehrlicher zu sagen
wir brauchen auch eine Steuerreform wo
tatsächlich auch einige Gruppen stärker
belastet werden okay wenn er sich jetzt
noch ein bisschen umgewindet wer das
jetzt genau
meine Frage Verständnisfrage bitte also
als ein völliger Laie aber betroffen
sind sie als neuer weiterer
Bestsellerautor jetzt sie sind auch
wieder dran damit den das klar ist ja
würde ich gerne verstehen
wie wird das was man dann vorschlagen
hat dann tatsächlich gegen finanziert
die Entlastung ich finde das sehr gut
dass meine Mittelstand der zum Teil sehr
ungerecht belastet entlastet aber wo
kommen die anderen Mehrwert tatsächlich
brauchen werden natürlich ist die
einfachste Antwort die aber auch
trotzdem richtig ist überwachsen
wenn dieses Land ich dachte jedes Jahr
mit ein zwei Prozent wächst oder drei
Prozent kriegen wir Steuereinnahmen und
wir können das alles finanzieren aber
darüber hinaus gibt es auch unbequeme
antworten dass wir beispielsweise sagen
unsere Sozialversicherung können wir so
nicht weiter am Leben halten auch
finanziell und wir müssen beispielsweise
darüber nachdenken ob wir nicht sagen es
geht nicht weiter mit dem ausufern
sondern wir sagen vielleicht brauchen
wir eine sozialstaatsquote von 30
Prozent und da ist Schluss ähnlich wie
die Schuldenbremse was meine These ist
ja dass man sagt 30% des Sozialproduktes
kann ich für das
verstehst das heißt in der Konsequenz
dass wir sogar eine noch soziale Politik
machen als wir jetzt machen ist meine
These weil sie dann ganz anders mit dem
Geld umgehen sehen wir jetzt auch bei
der Schuldenbremse dadurch dass die
Politik diese Bremse hat
gehen wir in normalen Zeiten ich lasse
das jetzt die aktuelle Zeit mal weg weil
wir die Schuldenbremse aussetzen mit dem
Geld noch mal anders um und können nicht
alles versprechen und bei den
Sozialleistungen ist es ähnlich wenn wir
sagen wir haben eine sozialstaatsquote
von 30 %. da ist Schluss dann werden
beispielsweise ich sage es jetzt mal
ganz offen dann wird die CDU nicht eine
dritte mütterrente versprechen können
sondern muss sagen wir werden jetzt
gezielt diejenigen unterstützen z.B
diejenigen die im Alter von 60 Jahren
eine Pflegerin nicht mehr arbeiten kann
oder jemand der auf dem Dach unterwegs
ist der bekannte Dachdecker 90% der
Dachdecker sind mit 60 nicht mehr auf
dem Dach die wollen wir jetzt stärker
konzentriert unterstützen aber die
Politik mit der Gießkanne mit vollen
Händen können wir uns nicht mehr leisten
ja aber man muss sich mal klar machen
was das heißt also im Augenblick ist die
Quote der Sozialleistung bei 40 % und
doch
31,5 nachlesen
perfekt parat haben ja okay also
in der Tat muss man vielleicht mal
nachgucken aber das Problem ist ja sie
zahlen aus der aus den Sozialkassen die
Pflege die Krankenkasse und die Rente
alles drei ist bereits unterfinanziert
Fliege weiß jeder die es gibt zu wenig
Pflegekräfte die Pflegekräfte verdienen
auch zu wenig da müsste man eigentlich
anheben Krankenhäuser weiß auch jeder
Krankenschwestern verdienen zu wenig in
die Krankenhäuser sind konzentrieren die
Krankenhäuser sind am Anschlag
die brauchen eigentlich auch mehr Geld
Rente die Rente in Deutschland ist
wirklich sehr niedrig das gilt nur nicht
für die Pension mit bei ungefähr ja also
wenn man das
wirklich natürlich aber zu sagen ist es
vielleicht im Durchschnitt tausend und
bei den Männern ist es höher aber
vielleicht 1500 das heißt auch die Rente
kann man jetzt nicht noch weiter kürzen
so und dann frage ich mich man kann
jetzt nicht sagen das tun sie ja dass
man bei den Sozialleistungen weiter
kürzen will um Steuerentlastung zu
finanzieren und ich wiederhole mich die
im Ende auch sehr stark wohlhabenden
zugute kommen so sondern mit ihren
Wohlhaben ja wenn Sie einen Konzept
hätten könnte man das ja detaillierter
diskutieren aber sie haben kein Konzept
das was wir gehört haben würde vor allen
Dingen
sagen sie das so einfach es ist einfach
so einmal abräumen das ist wirklich
spannend
die Rente mit 63 und die Mütter
sie sagen am Ende werden die auch
entlassen warum weil der Soli fällt weg
also der Soli zahlen nur noch Leute die
einzelnen 80.000 Euro
5% zusätzlich auf die auf die Steuerlast
so und das wegfällt zehn Milliarden die
dann fehlen wenn er wegfährt
erhöhen die werden dann oben auch
entlastet wenn ja in der in der bekannte
genau
5,5% und packen dann drei oder vier
Prozent drauf habe ich das richtig
verstanden also die Zukunft das ist die
Idee wenn man wenn ich ein Limit richtig
verstehe wenn man den Soli abschafft
dass das eingebettet wird in eine große
Steuerreform es geht um eine große
Steuerung wo dann aber entsprechend muss
man aber auch sagen dann eben einerseits
der wegfallende Soli dann eben
kompliziert und durch entsprechende
Steigerungen oben ja plus wenn man eben
unten noch entlassen will muss man
sozusagen zusätzlich oben noch Regen
lassen weil sonst ist sozusagen nicht
genug Geld da das heißt
nicht perfekt durchrechnen wie wir reden
hier wie Sie sagen so ein bisschen ins
Blaue aber es macht trotzdem wahnsinnig
Spaß mal ein bisschen grundsätzlicher zu
werden
also wenn ich richtig verstehe gedeckelt
werden sollen wir gleichzeitig wie
vorher man zu Recht hat sehr viele
verpflichtende Ausgaben haben und für
manches zu wenig ausgeben wo würde
gekürzt wo würden keine Sozialausgaben
mehr geleistet die wir jetzt Leisten
sind ungefähr bei 30%. ich glaube solche
Wahlkämpfe wie 2017 nicht mehr
stattfinden damals hat die SPD eine
Rente mit 63 versprochen und auch
umgesetzt die sehr teuer waren heute
fehlen die 10 bis 20 Prozent Fachkräfte
die wir eigentlich bräuchten diejenigen
die Unterstützung nötig haben die mit 60
gar nicht mehr auf dem Dach stehen die
Pflegerinnen und Pfleger die körperlich
kaputt sind diese leer ausgegangen
stattdessen hat man so eine Wohltat
gemacht bei der CDU muss sich selbst
kritisch sagen ob das so richtig war mit
der mütterrente muss man auch bezweifeln
weil diejenigen die es wirklich brauchen
zum Beispiel jemand der in der
Grundsicherung ist dort wo das
angerechnet es ist passiert ich möchte
nur dass sie in Zukunft
in Wahlkämpfen sondern
Überbietungswettbewerb wer die teuersten
Wahlkampfversprechen macht und gerade im
sozialen Bereich ist sehr interessant
dass das nicht mehr gemacht wird weil
das am Ende des Tages
es geht alles über Schulden gemacht
alles und diese Schulden sind vor allen
Dingen auch von dem Hintergrund der
staatlichen Ausgaben das heißt nämlich
die Inflation geht hoch und das sehen
wir jetzt sechs bis acht Prozent
Inflation da steckt uns allen in den
Knochen und wenn wir da rauskommen
wollen muss der Staat bei sich erstmal
anfangen mit dem Geld auskommen